I feel like I could do anything on the
course RJ Barrett the bounce pass and
the tank really just trying to be the
best player I could do it's a bonus when
your godson is the best 17 year old
basketball player on the planet Nash
became the Godfather of the future
number one ranked high school basketball
player through his friendship with RJ's
father Roland a friendship formed when
Steve and Roland played together on the
Canadian national team he's my godfather
so whenever I need something just a
quick text and he gets back to me you
know you think about who in your life
could you trust if you're not there and
your kid has to grow you know who could
you trust to be there to teach them the
right things to model the right
behaviors to me that would definitely
with Steve during our playing careers
you know we had a really strong bond
that I think is will last forever and
there's been much of the reason why
everyone asked me to be RJ's godfather
last time I played RJ 101 was 2015 in
the summer I beat him it was closer than
out of liked it to be and I'm gonna take
that win and run with it and hopefully
never have to defend it in my life
I remember watching them play someone
won and the guard it was maybe 14 15 was
physical if he was he put a little wood
on us it was fun feeling he was
outgrowing the competition in his
hometown of Mississauga Canada RJ told
his father he wanted to transfer to high
school basketball powerhouse Mountain
verdict Adam II outside of Orlando
Florida it's not are you sure this is
what you want to do and you said dad I'm
ready when I moved to Monteverde caddy
week and I was able to go to Jordan Ben
international game and just started
Steven over from there I really showed
me that I could really play at this
level and we want RJ to be coached no
easy ride you know make it difficult
make it hard put him through the fire
because you need to prepare him for
everything in 2017 Barrett's confidence
and abilities brought him to the
international stage where he would
represent Canada in the under-19 FIBA
World Championship on average he was two
years younger than
all other players we did it this summer
one VP at the FIBA do 19 World
Championships and that was one of the
main factors at me classifying going
2018 unbelievable
he is just utterly sensational folks RJ
being the star of the show even though
he was a couple years younger than
everybody it was a long time coming and
a lot of hard work and a lot of I think
execution on a vision that was
developing players Barrett reclassified
up from the 2019 to the 2018 recruiting
class he will attend college a year
early committing to Duke University he
would check another goal off of his list
finishing high school as the number one
overall ranked recruit
[Applause]
can't complain about going to Duke
University so he's in a great place with
great coach great tradition is there a
better leader and college basketball
than Coach K so if there's somebody that
can lead you through something like that
I think we're we're in the right place
for me the most impressive thing about
RJ as a basketball player is just feel
for the game light and the fact that
he's in the public eye and he gets a lot
of attention and he's still able to
maintain his humility and in the humble
way that he carries himself and for
somebody with such ability makes you
extremely proud